[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so verließ
welt das ende des jahres nachschauen und
heute gibt es das letzte torten rezept
in diesem jahr in einer woche ist
silvester und das neue jahr kommt und
ich hab mir gedacht was machen wir dann
dieses jahr für eine torte letztes jahr
habe ich jetzt diese hut torte gemacht
mit dem uhrenmacher und dieses jahr soll
es mal eine einfache retorte werden die
auch vielleicht jeder nachmachen kann
hier ist sehe ich habe einfach nur
gebacken und zwar habe ich hier in der
mitte eine torte sie hat eine richtig
leckere füllung seiner mascarpone sahne
creme und außen rum habe ich noch
muffins das ist dann auch ideal gerade
wenn zum beispiel kinder dabei sind die
vielleicht nicht gerade ein großes
tortenstück essen möchten sondern sich
hier einfach ein muffin wegnehmen können
und ihr könnt ihr dort auch gerne
gestalten wie ihr möchtet ich fand
einfach so die idee mit der uhr und den
zahlen ganz cool und ich zeige euch
jetzt zuerst einmal wie ich den teig
hersteller ihnen habe ich eine torte die
hat so ein bisschen spekulatius gewürze
mit dabei und eine waffel orangen frucht
einlage also superfrucht ich super
lecker und vom aufwand her finde ich
lohnt sich auf jeden fall für silvester
hier sind schon mal die zutaten für die
torte als für den tortenboden für den
teig traurig 4 200 gramm zucker eine
prise salz und etwas vanille extrakt
jeweils 200 milliliter mineralwasser und
sonnenblumenöl 265 gramm mehl 1 3
viertel teelöffel backpulver 120 gramm
gemahlene mandeln die habe ich jetzt
gemacht und ich habe ich noch eine
gewürzmischung jeweils einen halben
teelöffel zimt und irgendwann ein
viertel teelöffel karton und etwas nelly
pulver ich nehme es zuerst einmal die
eier und die werden gemeinsam mit dem
zucker dem salz und dem wandel extrakt
für etwa fünf bis zehn minuten cremig
verrührt
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich noch bei niedriger stufe
das wasser und das öl dazu da ist die
zutaten kurz einrühren
[Musik]
das mehl für mich jetzt mit dem
backpulver und den gemahlenen mandeln
und den gewürzen und hebt die zutaten
dann noch kurz unter
[Musik]
der teig ist ein bisschen flüssiger
daher schlage ich jetzt mal den bug ring
in backpapier 1
so kann ich verhindern dass ausläuft
[Musik]
und jetzt will ich den teig hier rein
die backform hat einen durchmesser von
20 zentimetern und ich habe dir
zwischenzeit übrigens genutzt um eine
garage stellen eine weiße da gibt es das
rezept auch schon auf dem kanal für die
garage wird einfach die schokolade
zerkleinert werden wir die sahne
aufgekocht und alles verriet jetzt sehe
ich den teig hier am rand so ein
bisschen hoch so kann etwas
gleichmäßiger hoch backen so kommt dann
schon in den vorgeheizten backofen bei
170 grad ober unterhitze und da brauche
etwa 35 bis 45 minuten ich mache auf
jeden fall die stäbchen probe die
zwischenzeit wirst dich jetzt um auch
den martinstag herzustellen
und da nehme ich jetzt schokoladen
muffins weil die vor allem kindern sehr
gut schmecken
ich zeige euch mal die zutaten für den
martinstag traurig 150 gramm zucker 160
gramm mehl 40 gramm kakaopulver einen
halben teelöffel backpulver und viertel
teelöffel natron und eine prise salz 100
gramm back feste schoko drops etwas
vanille extrakt zwei eier und jeweils
150 milliliter milch und sonnenblumenöl
gibt es geht es ganz einfach die
trockenen zutaten werden nämlich zuerst
in einer schüssel verrühren
[Musik]
und jetzt alles kurz verrühren bis sich
alles schön verbunden hat jetzt kommen
noch die flüssigen zutaten dazu
natürlich cfd vanille und auch die
anderen flüssigen und normalerweise
nehme ich immer gerne buttermilch weil
die einfach so ein bisschen säure hat
ich hatte jetzt leider nur normale milch
da und deswegen gebe ich noch ein schuss
essig mit rein denn ich habe hier nach
rom mit dem teig und natron braucht
immer ein bisschen säure zum aufgehen
das ist einfach ein schuss essig oder
zitronensaft jetzt alles ganz kurz
verrühren
jetzt nämlich ein portionierer und
befülle die muffin förmchen gleichmäßig
[Musik]
der kuchen ist jetzt abgekühlt zum
abkühlen habe ich ihn nach dem backen
einfach auf einen torten gitter gelegt
und so mit einem tuch abgedeckt und
jetzt ist es schön kalt die muffins
kühlen auch gerade noch ab jetzt geht es
an die füllung damit die torte schön
leicht wird mache ich sie ein bisschen
fruchtig und eine richtig leckere pasta
pudel frischkäse creme
ich zeige euch mal die zutaten für die
creme brauche ich 500 gramm magerquark
250 gramm aus capone 400 gramm
schlagsahne etwas vanille extrakt 10
teelöffel sabbath und 70 gramm butter zu
kaufen so ernst nehme ich jetzt die
mascarpone die muss nämlich zuerst mal
gerd gerührt werden am besten direkt mit
der sahne
der ist übrigens mit mascarpone quark
frischkäse creme aber ich wollte sagen
wenn ihr keine mascarpone mögt oder kein
quartier könnt das alles auch schön
austauschen also das geht auch die
breitest jetzt kommt hier ein bisschen
sahne dazu und dann kann ich die krähen
so ein bisschen glatt rühren wenn ich
akku habe wenig akku hätte dann können
dies glatt rühren muss kurzeinsätzen
ok jetzt kommt ihr die restliche sahne
dazu jemand voraus dass hier am besten
eine größere schüssel nehmen damit sie
nicht so sehr schritt dann kommt hier
salat dazu und dann kann ich die creme
frei schlagen
[Musik]
am besten noch nicht ganz fest steif
schlagen
denn jetzt versuche ich noch den quark
das mache ich ganz kurz in das separaten
schüssel und zwar mit puderzucker und
vanille extrakt ruhig ein bisschen
großzügig so ein telefon oder zockereien
und kurz verrühren
[Musik]
und jetzt könnte einfach nur noch die
cvag rehm in die sahne creme geben ein
bisschen unterheben oder auch ganz
vorsichtig mit dem schneebesen verrühren
die creme stelle ich jetzt kurz kühl und
zeigt euch mal die zutaten für die
frucht einlage die machen wir jetzt
nämlich aus orange apfel und immer schön
winterlich jetzt und das hier kann man
einfach sorgt dafür brauche ich zwei
orangen und etwa 300 milliliter
orangensaft insgesamt einen apfel 30
gramm ingwer und fünf gramm aga ich
nehme jetzt zuerst einmal den ingwer und
den brauche ich jetzt gar nicht schälen
ich schneide einfach nur die hier diese
harten stellen weg und die schale
die könnte jetzt auch so ein bisschen
einfach so abreiben die schäden jetzt
gar nicht komplett es reicht schon aus
und jetzt kann ich ihnen einfach fein
würfeln
den apfel werde ich auch schön und den
auch würfeln
jetzt tauschen sagt an der reihe wie
gesagt brauche ich da ungefähr 300
milliliter und teilt mit dass aus den
zwei orangen nicht reichte ich mir
einfach noch eine
ihr könnt aber auch den o saft aus der
flasche nehmen
[Musik]
da gebe ich jetzt noch als agatha wird
dazu und für die zutaten jetzt und dann
kommt hier auf dem herd apple und
irgendwann stücke die gebe ich auch
gleich mit dazu
ich lasse die masse aufkochen und zwei
minuten mindestens sprudelnd kochen
damit dass agrana türlich auch wirken
kann
[Musik]
die masse muss dann auf jeden fall ganz
gut abkühlen
die stelle ich mal ganz kurz zur seite
und kann jetzt hier schon mal den
tortenboden weiterverarbeiten
den habe ich jetzt bereits herausgelöst
und der war auch gut in der kühlung
nicht schneidet ihnen einfach durch
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die torte film ich habe
die garantie habe ich ganz gut im
kühlschrank damit sie ein bisschen
fester wird
ich habe sie in einen spritzbeutel
gefüllt und vorne loch thüle jetzt
nämlich wichtig dass die quark sahne
creme nicht mit dem von der in
verbindung kommt das heißt die sahne
creme bekommt innen und außen herum
spritzen jetzt so einen rand aus ghana
und das ist dann praktisch die isolation
und so gelangt die creme nicht nach
außen und beschädigt den vom tor nicht
[Musik]
die creme habe ich jetzt auch in einem
spritzbeutel soll jetzt ein bisschen
einfacher und kann die jetzt hier
einführen
[Musik]
da verteile ich jetzt die frucht einlage
drüber und ihr könnt ihr auch gerne als
frucht einlage einfrieren also als diese
frucht anlage die sonst gerne mache hier
wollte ich einfach ein bisschen flüssig
gehalten und so rein verteilen und die
wird er dann wirklich in der torte
gleich vom abkühlen fest in dem die
nicht süß genug ist da kann auch ein
bisschen zucker zufügen
aber ich finde gerade das zusammenspiel
schön von der säure aus den orangen
bisschen schärfer aus dem ingwer und der
rest der torte ist ja auch ganz süß
nicht ganz fies aber vielleicht ja gut
aus
da kommt jetzt der zweite tag drüber und
dann mache ich das ganze noch einmal
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt der deckel drauf
und hier muss ich jetzt einfach nur
aufpassen dass die creme nicht nach
außen gelangt daher hier noch ein
bisschen gar strand und dann kann ich
die torte und noch mal kurz kühl stellen
und dann die gesamte torte mit der
garage einstreichen
jetzt gefällt mir das schon richtig gut
sie kommt jetzt noch mal in den
kühlschrank für etwa eine halbe stunde
dann wird sie schön fest und dann kann
ich schon schwarzen von dor nehmen
ausrollen und die torte damit einkleiden
die machen sind jetzt auch schon kalt
und die sehen wirklich super aus aber
für meinen zweck muss ich jetzt ein
bisschen zu schneiden
ich finds ja normalerweise immer schön
wenn sie in koppl haben jetzt muss ich
den hobel wegschneiden und dann
bestreichen sie mit etwas hotel ihr
könnt aber zum beispiel auch die
restliche kanals nehmen also was euch
besser schmeckt
[Musik]
hier habe ich jetzt 200 gramm schwarze
modell schokolade weich geknetet und
jetzt ganz dünn ausgerollt
jetzt nehme ich dann ausstecher dessen
bisschen größer als die muffins kann
jetzt hier kreise ausstechen und die
damit überlegen und schön mit den
fingern glatt streichen
[Musik]
auf den rest habe ich jetzt hier noch
buchstaben und sterne ausgestochen und
damit die schön gold werden nämlich
einfach dieses gold mit alex prey und
kann sie besprühen und trocknen lassen
und anschließend werde ich dann die
sterne und die buchstaben einfach mit
etwas essbarem kleber auf die muffins
draufkleben und die sind dann schon
fertig
die zwischenzeit habe ich jetzt auch
genutzt um die zeiger der uhr
auszuschneiden
die habe ich auch aus schwarzer
modelliert schokolade gemacht und
besprühte gold den fondant rolle ich am
liebsten auf etwas becker stärker aus
die club nämlich nicht und ich kann sie
später auch einfach wieder wegwischen
die torte besprühte jetzt mit etwas marc
prins trade damit die von dort decke gut
dran haftet jetzt kann ich die fondant
decke ganz streichen und die überreste
wegschneiden die reste rolle ich jetzt
noch zusammen und überziehe auch das
skateboard damit
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt die torte aus und diese
zeiger sind auch schon schön
durchgetrocknet und auch richtig schön
gold damit die torte noch ein bisschen
spektakulärer wird habe ich jetzt hier
eine schablone und zwar nehme ich ein
bisschen wachs papier ihr könnt aber
auch backpapier nehmen und das schneide
ich jetzt kleine sterne aus teilweise
habe ich sie auch ausgestanzt und zwar
habe ich da so einen stern aus stand
sondern da kann man das nämlich hier
dran machen und so kann die schablone
netz ausschneiden und die torte oder mit
dem metallic spree besprühen
[Musik]
jetzt hält die schablone hier drauf
legen und es liebe ich so an wachs
papier das haftet so ein bisschen dran
und kann dann das metall extra vorher
gut durchschütteln und dann vorsichtig
trümmer sprühen
[Musik]
nur so gesprenkelt das gefällt mir gut
wo würdest du gerne sie torte
angeschnitten lieber morath also was ich
genial finde jetzt kann sich natürlich
jeder einfach diese muffins wegnehmen so
hätte sie gerne angeschnitten bauten
entwurf nicht erst kann ich bitte auf 99
18 uhr ist kommt gerade jemand oder auch
noch jetzt gar nicht sagt aber ich habe
zwölf wo es immer gerade ausgabe 12 oben
will
wir haben hinten und sagt 3 uhr dann
wenn sie nach rechts einfach ich weiß
nicht ich verstehe dass seine bahn hat
ich gebe jetzt steht mit happy
vielleicht wäre dann ein bisschen hätten
ja vielleicht aber auch nur vielleicht
gibt es irgendwas dass du nächstes jahr
anders machen ja ich werde ich öfter
einkaufen schicken
das sind sowohl haas als gewicht was wir
anders machen wir das gemacht
meistens wenn ich das nicht mehr los ja
das ist zu spät ist zu spät warum was
willst du anders machen sagt was liegt
ihr auf dem herzen
ich würde mehr sport treiben weniger
ärger da steht doch schon geärgert wo
ich mein einhorn was ich will mir
wichtig mich weniger ärger ja ich kann
das gar nicht glauben dass zum glück auf
kamera um mein gott gib mir mal deinen
teller
ich will ein besserer mensch werden
dieses jahr aber nichts das ist schon
gut ein dankeschön noch besser da kam
ich wirklich seriös werden habe ich auch
vor jetzt okay da bin ich jetzt mal
gespannt
lecker schmecker heute habe ich ganz
vergessen com oratorische probieren ein
frohes neues jahr mora dankeschön wir
auch sinn
ein bisschen haben wir ja noch ich habe
mal angst vor den dingern probiert und
geschmeckt damit irgendwann und orange
und apfel schmeckt klasse möglich
gleich geht doch auch niemand richtig
sagte ja und ich habe gut gelder ich
möchte nächstes jahr übrigens auch
weniger torte essen
echt jetzt habe ich jetzt nicht mehr so
viele packen kann sich und einstellen
der die ganze hat probiert
jack ma gern machen sondern
bewerbungsverfahren gleichauf ja also
werde ich dir gerne nächstes jahr torten
test juli werden
bewerbt euch unter murat celik svend de
den ganzen tag schon alles auswerten
über die jahre und ich mache diesen
urlaub mit dass jeder wie gesagt wird
dass sich melden möchte kann sich gerne
bei uns melden werden alle trocken von
der cd probieren vielleicht keine
gewichtsprobleme hat schon gegangen ist
sehr mutiger sein
was dort viel essen können gute gene
haben den sport treiben und allgemein
gesund sein
also jetzt bin ich mal gespannt murat
ist die aber noch nicht vorbei wir haben
wir noch eine woche am 31 dieses jahr
kommt übrigens ein richtig tolles video
online kein rezept aber da dürft euch
schon mal drauf freuen
falls ihr dieses rezept nachmachen
möchte was wirklich nicht so aufwendig
ist und wirklich super mega cool für
silvester dann schaut auf meinem blog
top selling - blog.de
da steht noch mal alles ganz genau und
ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen und wir sehen uns dann wieder
nächste woche bis dann tschüss
jetzt gibt es nämlich noch ein paar
silvester snacks ja lasst mal zu
das bildungs und ich nehme 10 77 ich
meine glückszahl
sie sind 13 also wie einst um die 30 2 1
[Musik]
b
das war doch gut weitergeht